los ataques con drones han tenido en
guardia a las autoridades rusas durante
todas las últimas horas la primera hora
de esta mañana conocíamos que se había
tenido que cerrar el espacio aéreo en la
zona de San Petersburgo debido a un
objeto Volador no identificado ya se ha
reabierto pero también en Moscú ha caído
o ha sido derribado un dron en los
alrededores de la ciudad en un pueblo
situado a unos 60 70 kilómetros de la
capital rusa al parecer el objetivo del
dron según han dicho las autoridades
rusas era una central de distribución de
gas el suministro de energía no se ha
visto afectado y los servicios secretos
rusos están en la zona investigando lo
sucedido el gobierno ruso también ha
denunciado que durante esta noche
Ucrania ha lanzado dos ataques con
drones en distintas regiones del sur de
Rusia